we've got the brand new iPhone 10s and
10's max this is the gold 512 gigabyte
model it's got a beautiful gold Apple
logo here gold iPhone on the side before
I open this I just want to show you
where we started from this is the first
iPhone box started from here now we're
here what a beautiful family you have
here okay now we can open so much like
most of their iPhone a box seems we've
got our paperwork right here here they
are look at you even though I just saw
these at the Apple event having them
here in my own home and in my own two
hands some people say I overreact I've
tried really hard not to overreact maybe
I'm not the one overreacting maybe
you're the ones under reacting it's not
my problem it's your problem
look at these beauties this is such an
incredible color I just can't get over
how perfect this gold is I've been
waiting for this gold since they started
introducing gold phones because every
time they would introduce a gold phone I
was like oh I like it it's cool but it's
not the gold that I want you guys
remember I did have a gold phone
previously I had the iPhone 8 which was
more of a blush tone so then I did have
it was the iPhone 6 I actually got that
one I waited in line well there's
somebody else here surprise the middle
of nowhere in North Carolina first in
line the phone line forms here oh this
was the 6s that I got in gold they are
about the same size and form factor
overall blast back so this gold I felt
was a little bit too yellow ii like
these colors are pretty similar so this
is the 8 this is the 10s Maxx and I'm
hoping that I can even give you guys a
really good color demonstration you can
see that this 8 is a little more pinkish
whereas this has really interesting kind
of like a holographic reflectiveness to
it I don't know if that's the technical
term but that's what we're gonna call it
you guys need a size comparison the 10s
max is about the same size as the plus
model phones just the regular tennis is
about the same size as the iPhone 10
let's see what else we have in the box
earpods standard issue lightning cables
and
power bricks oh man I forgot you didn't
even actually need to use my knife I
brought our beautiful gold knife for
this unboxing this knife looks to be a
little bit too yellow gold I don't want
to smudge this up what we've got to do
it my precious I've still never seen
Lord of the Rings
how many iPhone unboxings am I going to
make that joke and not actually get the
reference
yeah it's turning on ok well this is
starting up we've got another one
I just wanna create a little like a
small child so weird to have a huge
phone again
we've got face ID already to set up the
belt I got some cases whoo this is
Jenna's favorite color well it's a nice
leather smell now you can't even tell
that I have a gold phone I like the blue
though cuz it is a good complement to
the gold here's this brown leather case
is this more of a tan color the official
name is sad around super-classy so some
of the differences between the 10s and
the 10 is obviously it comes in a much
larger size so this is the tennis Max
and a 10s which looks very similar to
the previous version it has an 8 12 chip
which is a much faster processor so
everything that you do on your phone
will be a little bit faster the back
facing cameras have
so this allows for faster autofocus and
improved low-light photos the super HDR
feature is pretty cool it captures a
bunch of photos all at once merges them
together for the perfect shot I also
love the advanced portrait mode you can
adjust the aperture after you take a
photo so that background blur that
everyone loves you can set it to however
much or however little you want
so essentially you should just be able
to go out push a button and take an
incredible picture it's really taking
the yard out of being a photographer
isn't it just push your button and voila
magic do I look like super half the time
I end up taking iPhone pictures instead
of using my expensive camera it's easier
and the end up looking just as good
sometimes I went a little more in depth
and some of the things that were
announced in all of the new phones and
the watches in my reaction video from
the Apple event okay I'm gonna stop
talking because I don't take this thing
out it's some cool slow-mo b-roll
because you know that's what I like to
do I'm not such a sucker for slow-mo
[Music]
so we're now down here by the beach I
want to test out some more of a slow-mo
video and because the Sun is super harsh
this is gonna be the perfect situation
to test out the smart HDR and the new
extended dynamic range in the video
because it's so bright the phone will
automatically be able to adjust the
highlights and the contrast and merge
everything all into one photo so the
photos in the video won't be too
overexposed
I need to show you what Jenna's doing
just making it work this is great
Oh someone else's trash okay
[Music]
demo of some of the absence of a ARCA -
I'm so excited for the future of AR it's
probably one of my most favorite things
so this app is called night sky so
basically it gives you entire view over
the world stars constellations it'll
even show you the International Space
Station so there it is case you're
wondering where it's at today look at
the solar system generate a live sky
tour for any location time on earth
simply choose a location okay let's see
what's happening in Cupertino welcome to
the sky to avoid to apetito over the
next night the stargazing conditions
tonight will be good though particular
constellation in zenith at 8:28 all
right elemento element tail tau an
element tau so you can do multiple
people in this so if you click this you
can create a room so a bunch of people
can also join in but I clearly don't
have any friends in here right now the
screen scenery looks beautiful let's do
that okay we're a scan the surface the
whole table yes
here's my world so we can look up
I think augmented reality is probably
one of my favorite things I like VR but
I feel like VR takes you out of the
element I'm going inside now like I'm
seeing things
look there's a ball over here to you
ball I don't know if I can kick it I can
do is look around him look on top of it
I'm also screen recording and doing this
at the same time so that's you see have
a lot of resources it is there's fire
here now the app that we're gonna test
out now it was called memorize and this
is a language learning app so using AR
it'll identify objects that it sees and
I'll tell you how to say them and
whatever language you're trying to learn
so let's learn some new words the potted
plant deep chop Johnson oh come on no
detail can see the tops lenses well next
time I go to Germany I'm gonna be sure
to use my new hood it also thought that
this potentially could be broccoli which
is incredible difficulty I can say that
theater broccoli this is freakin fun
Devils they're open what's this the
sickest gosh fiction oh come on
- wash pickin refrigerator oh it thinks
it's a bookcase
back up - Frank German is very very
difficult
Kapoor sink - I'm honestly trying well
let me take a picture you you're a
person it's telling it says divers
yes but in English the person okay what
else is around here diem ella tiene la
TM Ella it thinks it's soap so the cool
things is a clock detail it it the
toilet the toilet it D to a litter and
this is cool too because you can go in
here so it kind of gives you an entire
library of items so if you want to go
back and okay why does it think that's a
festival thinks it's the remote control
now thinks it's a cell phone do you know
how does a cell phone just Hindi I'm so
excited about all of the fun ar apps
that are coming out using a our kit -
there's so many more things that can be
implemented into AR so if you guys have
any favorite err apps please leave those
in the comments below and I look forward
to seeing what you guys are into how do
you say new cell phone in German no
noise handy noise handy they also
sentence to face ID is faster because of
the H bulb chip so lets us it out
so this notification telling me to water
my plants from 207 days ago I don't even
know how you're gonna be able to capture
this but ready yep oh it's definitely
faster
Wow Wow it's faster Jordan's gonna be so
happy
everybody tweet CaptainSparklez and tell
him that the iphone tennis has faster
face ID I know but he wants faster face
I do thank you so much for watching hope
you guys enjoyed it this iPhone 10
videos is a first look and unboxing and
some of my favorite features of course
as you know I will have plenty more
videos for you guys to be sure to
subscribe and of course hit the bell so
you be alerted when I make new videos
there's anything else that you would
like to see me make videos about whether
it's iPhone or not iPhone leave those in
the comments below and I look forward to
seeing what you guys have to say so I'll
see you later I'm dancing but there's no
music it's in my head
[Music]